sur la ferme du pré jolie donc on a 180
hectares qui permettent de nourrir le
troupeau d'une centaine de vaches
laitières donc on a
ensuite 60-70 génisses ou animaux à
viande puisque on fait un peu de viande
en vente directe aussi et on élève une
vingtaine de génisses par an donc 100 ha
son pâturage
et en prairie pour nourrir les animaux
on travaille à 10 sur la ferme donc
aujourd'hui on est quatre associés cinq
salariés temps plein et une apprentie
qui en école d'ingénieurs à bordeaux
parce qu'on a aussi à coeur de vouloir
former des gens on reçoit aussi pas mal
de se cacher tout au long de l'année n'a
converti la ferme l'agriculture
biologique il ya en 2011 donc à une
dizaine d'années pour nous ça a été
quand on était assez proche de
l'agriculture biologique donc on a eu
des adaptations à faire mais pas trop
importante aujourd'hui pour nous c'est
un plaisir de travailler sans engrais
chimiques et sans pesticides on a adapté
nos techniques nos méthodes de
production par rapport à ce contexte là
on a appris à faire pousser de l'herbe
sans engrais chimiques à faire pousser
du maïs sans pesticides pour
l'alimentation des vaches laitières la
ferme du pré joly donc on sait le
pâturage à partir de fin février au
maximum le pâturage de février à
novembre et puis l'hiver ou quand il n'y
a plus assez de pâturages ont nourri les
vaches avec du froid et séché en grange
donc là on est dans le bâtiment de
séchage et stockage en vrac du foin on
rentre le froid moitié sec 55 100 de
matières sèches ont fini de sécher avec
un séchage solaire où on capte la
chaleur du soleil sous les tôles pour
sécher le foin en deux à trois jours ça
nous permet de garder le plus possible
les nutriments du foin et d'avoir à la
fois le plus riche possible pour
l'autonomie de la ferme en alimentation
et aussi pour la santé des animaux
puisque on a plus de ligonnés mans et de
vitamines avec du séchage en grange dans
les aliments et ça nous permet de jouer
aussi énormément sur la santé des
animaux puisque on a très très peu de
problèmes et d'intervention de
vétérinaires sur l'année on transforme
presque tout le lait sur la ferme un peu
une petite partie de la production est
vendue à la coopérative agrial et on
transforme ça tous les ans une gamme
large de produits laitiers donc ça va
de la crème fraîche au beurre lait yao
nature aromatisés des crèmes dessert
vanille chocolat riz au lait semoule
semoule de maïs population au lait des
fromages frais comme des fromages
combattu en fait celle des fromages
lactique affiné au site x17 ici à saint
marcellin qu'on appelle le robichaud
robichon des tomes donc une grosse
quantité d'hommes aussi qu'elle soit
nature ou aux fenugrec au poids vous au
cumin galerie locale a été pour nous un
moyen de pouvoir rentrer en contact avec
notamment les collèges puisqu'on n'avait
pas les moyens de démarcher les gens
d'aller à la rencontre des gens et ça
c'est vraiment un très gros avantage
d'être sur un listing de producteurs
locaux qui veulent travailler avec les
écoles et en ça se passe plutôt bien
faut apprendre à travailler ensemble
mais ça nous a permis de fortement
développer puisqu'on est passé de 5,6
école qu on fournissait avant la
création de la grille locale a
aujourd'hui au moins une quarantaine
d'écoles qui achètent nos produits pour
certains de manière très régulière ça
devient des vrais partenariats pour
certains et pour nous ça a du sens de
fabriquer des produits laitiers pour les
vendre aux écoles de la vienne notamment
c'était un bon choix que le choix des
élus du département où d'autres
partenaires locaux de s'investir dans
cette démarche qui nous permet d'aborder
ce les marchés publics sachant que les
marchés publics pour des petites fermes
comme les nôtres c'est quelque chose qui
est carrément dans la structuration
actuelle inabordable à bientôt sur la
grille local 86